the eu is currently negotiating
a new trade and
investment agreement with the usa it's about
a lot
and yes it affects us all that's the
point of it
creating transatlantic trade and investment partners
or ttp will benefit us in europe and at the
same time the rest of the  benefiting the world
for european consumers this means
more choice and better
value for money
this is good news for businesses too
but it's not just about
finding bargains or
boosting the european economy and
creating new jobs
there are other benefits too
agreement will help set new rules
for a better and fair global
economy and build an even
stronger partnership with the us
we listen and take all opinions
seriously learn more about tdp and
share your thoughts